una nueva prueba de corea del norte pone
en alerta a sus vecinos japón y corea
del sur confirmaron el lanzamiento de un
misil de corto alcance norcoreano un
movimiento que fue rechazado por tokio y
seúl sector y medición y el gobierno
japonés aumentará más que nunca la
alerta y la vigilancia en cualquier caso
estamos analizando la situación del
lanzamiento
marciano yo que ni chiste
creemos que el lanzamiento del misil es
lamentable en un momento en el que
necesitamos estabilizar urgentemente la
situación en la península de corea
francia se sumó al repudio y afirmó que
los repetidos lanzamientos se socavan la
paz y la seguridad regional e
internacional las condenas también
llegaron desde washington y londres
y es que esta es la tercera prueba de
misiles en menos de un mes en medio de
mensajes encontrados de pyongyang que a
la vez se han mostrado abierto al
diálogo con seúl justo antes del
lanzamiento del enviado de corea del
norte defendió el derecho de su país a
contar con armas para protegerse de las
hostilidades de eeuu pese a la
prohibición vigente de la onu para
digamos acción juntos a ottón min dado
que la alianza militar entre eeuu y
corea del sur aumenta las amenazas
militares contra corea del norte
nadie puede negar el derecho legítimo a
la autodefensa para desarrollar probar
fabricar y comprar los sistemas de armas
equivalentes a los que poseen ellos
fundó conclusión al sound sonaban con
limitó el presidente surcoreano moon
jae-in repitió días atrás ante la onu
los llamados a poner fin formalmente a
la guerra de corea el conflicto terminó
en 1950 con un armisticio por lo que las
dos coreas siguen técnicamente en guerra
para avanzar en ese sentido pyongyang
exige que washington abandonen los
ejercicios militares con seúl y retire
todas las armas existentes en y
alrededor de la península